depuis ce lundi la russie est entrée
dans une nouvelle phase de sa campagne
de vaccination après avoir convié
progressivement les professions
prioritaires et les personnes âgées
la vaccination est désormais ouverte à
tous et gratuitement et pour ce faire
des centres dédiés ont été ouverts comme
ici par exemple à l'opéra hélicon situé
dans un des plus anciens bâtiments de
moscou ce théâtre est consacrée à
l'opéra donc et aux concerts de musique
classique pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale
l'endroit servait d'hôpital c'est donc
naturellement que la direction du
théâtre s'est proposé est parmi les
premiers à se faire vacciner certains
sont familiers des lieux
en premier lieu je veux le faire pour
moi même pour être en sécurité lorsque
c'est tout d'abord dangereux pour moi en
tant que chanteur que cette maladie
touche gravement les capacités vocales
c'est un coup dur pour les poumons pour
les organes locaux
ce n'est pas bon pour l'heure qu'ils ont
j'estime que puisqu'on a une telle
opportunité
il faut certainement le faire il faut le
combattre parce qu'on en a marre bien
sûr on en a marre grâce aux autorités de
la ville de moscou des postes de
vaccination ont été créés ce qui à mon
avis est formidable parce qu'on est au
courant de ce qui se passe au royaume
uni où les gens se font vacciner même
dans les stations service actuellement
l'objectif est de terminer au plus vite
sa vaste rebooster un peu sur bravo mais
mis à part le cadre grandiose la
procédure elle se déroule comme partout
ailleurs c'est un beau patrimoine à
l'est de la piste pour se faire vacciner
à l'opéra helicon il n'est pas
nécessaire de s'inscrire davance il
suffit de présenter n'importe quelle
pièce d'identité de remplir un
formulaire de passer un examen médical
et enfin de se faire vacciner
ensuite il faut passer 30 minutes sous
surveillance médicale pour au total la
vaccination prend une quarantaine de
minutes
en même temps en fixent la date de la
seconde injection du patient puisque le
vaccin se fait tendre
autre endroit atypique est l'un des
symboles de la ville de moscou
le groom centre commercial huppé qui
donne sur la place rouge contribue lui
aussi à cette campagne de grande ampleur
la russie a dépassé cette semaine le cap
du premier million de vaccinés et les
autorités espèrent qu'avec le lancement
de cette campagne massive
ce chiffre pourra rapidement évolué